[Rires]
c'est une blague mais on a Jean-Michel
Arnaud qui est très investi dans la
délégation et qui était très investi
d'ailleurs aussi sur sur ce rapport
femme et ruralité d'ailleurs bien
écoutez officiellement je vous dis à
tous et à toutes je vous souhaite une
très belle année une année aussi
dynamique et constructive que l'année
2022 pour la délégation on a eu des
belles réussites des travaux qui nous
ont extrêmement
occupés et qui nous ont aussi impactés
psychologiquement je pense dans la
manière de mener ces travaux je pense
forcément à l'industrie pornographique
je remercie tout le monde pour son
investissement sur ce sujet et bien
cette année on a décidé de travailler
sur la santé des femmes au travail
à un moment où on parle du sujet des
retraites ça me paraît tout à fait
intéressant
d'envisager ce thème et puis forcément
aussi
la parentalité dans les territoires
ultramarins c'est les deux gros dossiers
qu'on avait choisi en début d'année donc
merci à tous d'être là ce matin déjà
pour cette première audition 2023 je
souhaite évidemment remercier comme
d'habitude l'équipe qui m'entoure et la
bienvenue souhaitez la bienvenue à les
l'équipe ne gagne pas en parité là non
plus semble-t-il puisque Guy nous a dit
moineau est parti la communication et
donc Caroline platvent nous a rejoint
donc bienvenue à Caroline on est très
heureux de vous accueillir dans cette
délégation qui ne chôment pas et qui des
sujets qu'on embrasse toujours avec
beaucoup de
consensualité si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi et c'est toujours intéressant quel
que soit les groupes politiques auxquels
nous pouvons intervenir les relations
sont extrêmement apaisées et les
rapports sont souvent votés à
l'unanimité s'il y avait eu un rapport
sur les retraites peut-être qu'il ne
l'aurait pas été c'est une boutade voilà
alors mesdames à nous chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs nous poursuivons
ce matin nos travaux sur la thématique
santé des femmes au travail avec trois
non deux rapporteurs pour l'instant la
troisième va arriver je pense et
Laurence Rossignol a été excusé donc
Laurence Cohen qui va nous rejoindre je
pense à Nick jacquemay qui est présente
et Marie-Pierre Richer je suis très
heureuse d'accueillir deux chers de
l'Institut national d'études de
démographie de l'Inde Émilie Counil
spécialisée dans l'étude des inégalités
sociales de santé et de leurs liens avec
le travail et l'environnement et
Constance beau-fils auteur d'une thèse
sur l'inactivité professionnelle au
cours du parcours de vie un déterminant
social de la santé des femmes aux âges
élevés réalisés à l'Université de Paris
Saclay c'est à ce moment-là que lors
d'Archos fait son entrée et sa classe sa
classe cet un territoire qui lui parle
pas forcément voilà et à l'Inde je dois
excuser Anne Lambert qui devait
également être présente mais ne peut
malheureusement pas être parmi nous elle
nous a cependant transmis des documents
présentant ces recherches sur les
horaires atypiques de travail et sur les
conditions de travail des femmes durant
la crise sanitaire donc merci à vous
mesdames pour votre présence matinale ce
matin vous nous présenterez les
résultats de vos travaux de recherche
portant sur les thématiques qui nous
intéressent plus particulièrement à
savoir les parcours professionnels et
conditions de travail des femmes et
leurs conséquences sur la santé
l'exposition des femmes au risque des
maladies professionnelles la prise en
compte de leur état de santé général de
leur grossesse et de leur maladie dans
le milieu professionnel et à ce
moment-là j'accueille Laurence Cohen
troisième rapporteur présente ce matin
les problématiques de santé mentale
charge mentale et risque de Burnout nous
sommes particulièrement intéressés par
les statistiques et les données que vous
nous communiquer au cours de cette
audition la richesse des données
recueillies par les Neds à l'échelle
nationale sera une source précieuse pour
nourrir ce rapport n'hésitez pas à nous
transmettre également des documents
écrits complémentaires après cette
audition mesdames s'agissant des risques
professionnels nous avons pu constater
que les femmes étaient de plus en plus
sujettes aux accidents de travail comme
aux troubles musculo-squelettiques
auxquels elles sont d'ailleurs deux fois
plus exposées que les hommes en revanche
les cancers d'origine professionnelle
restent souvent sous évalués chez les
femmes Emilie Counil nous présentera les
résultats de ces travaux sur cette
question des travaux de lunettes
conduits par Anne Lambert ont également
mis en évidence l'exposition croissante
des femmes aux horaires atypiques de
travail horaires de nuit tôt le matin
tard le soir ou le week-end avec des
conséquences néfastes sur leurs qualités
de vie et leur santé une étude de
l'IRCEM a par ailleurs montré une
augmentation de 26% du du sein dans le
cas du travail de nuit vous nous direz
comment tenir compte de ces inégalités
de genre en matière de prévention et de
réparation des maladies professionnelles
nous nous intéresserons également aux
liens entre conditions socio-économiques
et santé physique et mentales des femmes
les femmes sont assis deux fois plus
exposées que les hommes au risque de
dépression enfin constance beau-fils
nous présentera ses travaux de thèse sur
les conséquences d'épisodes d'inactivité
professionnelle sur la santé des femmes
âgées donc je vous laisse en plus tarder
la parole d'abord je crois Émilie Counil
qui va intervenir et donc je vous laisse
vous organiser ensuite et
donc on vous écoute mesdames
j'appuie là c'est parfait ça marche très
bien donc bonjour à toutes et à Monsieur
Merci beaucoup pour l'invitation tout
d'abord donc je commencerai mon propos
liminaire par une précaution préalable
et un avertissement donc la précaution
d'abord quant au sujet de la
sous-évaluation des questions de santé
au travail chez les femmes
il faut se rappeler que des chercheuses
c'était surtout des femmes ce sont
intéressées de longue date c'est à dire
depuis les années 80 déjà aux questions
de santé au travail des femmes y compris
en France de sorte qu'on ne peut pas
parler de déficit de connaissance en
général il faut distinguer les champs
disciplinaires notamment les sciences
sociales l'ergonomie des autres
disciplines plus biomédicales comme
l'épidémiologie et la toxicologie et
même au sein des disciplines elles-mêmes
les domaines de spécialisation la
sociologie du travail de la santé et du
genre s'est en saisie de manière assez
différente de ces questions au cours du
temps
néanmoins les problèmes des femmes
demeurent encore largement invisibles et
ceux encore plus que ceux des hommes
tandis qu'elles souffrent davantage
d'usure physique et psychiques les
hommes sont toujours plus exposés aux
dangers visibles et pour autant il ne
faut pas oublier que la faible
visibilité sociale et la faible prise en
charge des atteintes à la santé liées au
travail concerne les hommes aussi bien
que les femmes même si elle tend à être
plus marquées chez ces dernières j'en
donnerai des explications à partir de
recherche conduites sur les cancers
d'origine professionnelle
l'investissement ensuite quant à la
nature des recherches sur lesquelles je
vais m'appuyer donc les travaux que je
vais résumer en quelques mots ont été
conduits au début des années 2010 et au
milieu des années 2010 au Groupement
d'Intérêt scientifiques sur les cancers
d'origine professionnelle en
Seine-Saint-Denis le giscope 93 j'ai
apporté mes compétences en épidémiologie
au sein d'une équipe pluridisciplinaire
ou se côtoyait médecin de santé publique
et chercheuse en sciences sociales
c'est bien par le biais de ces frictions
disciplinaires et par des apports
conceptuels et méthodologiques qui
étaient alors étrangers à ma discipline
que j'ai pu faire évoluer mon propre
regard de chercheuse et prendre
conscience des biais de genre qui
peuvent générer des points aveugles dans
les connaissances en épidémiologie des
risques professionnels et ainsi
contribuer à renforcer les inégalités
sociales en matière de prévention et de
reconnaissance des atteintes à la santé
liées au travail
alors maintenant un mot sur l'enquête
dont il est question
partant du constat d'une faible
visibilité sociale des cancers d'origine
professionnelle l'équipe du giscope 93
s'est fixé pour objectif d'étudier les
inégalités sociales de cancer liées au
travail à partir d'une enquête de santé
publique conduite en Seine-Saint-Denis
le passé industriel de ce territoire sa
population longtemps ouvrière son
histoire migratoire mais aussi la
surmortalité par cancer observée au
milieu des années 90 en faisait un
terrain emblématique pour l'étude des
inégalités sociales d'exposition
professionnelle au cancérogène
au début des années 2000 l'équipe de ce
J a mis en place un dispositif d'enquête
original considérant les personnes
atteintes de cancer comme des
sentinelles indépendamment de leur passé
professionnel à partir du signalement
par les hôpitaux partenaires s'engager
alors une démarche de reconstitution des
histoires professionnelles fondées sur
le recueil par entretien de l'activité
de travail à chaque poste occupé qui
sert encore aujourd'hui de base pour
l'expertise pluridisciplinaire des
expositions à des expositions à des
cancérogènes connus
lorsque les expositions retrouvées sont
susceptibles d'ouvrir droit à une
réparation en maladie professionnelle un
suivi prospectif et proposé afin de
connaître et de faciliter les processus
d'accès à l'indemnisation la notion de
parcours
occupe ainsi une position centrale dans
cette enquête parcours professionnel
parcours d'exposition et parcours de
réparation sont patiemment documentés
alors passons maintenant à quelques
résultats de cette de cette recherche à
partir des données accumulées au cours
des 10 premières années de l'enquête sur
plus d'un millier de patientes et de
patients atteints de cancer des voies
respiratoires nous avons pu tirer quatre
principaux enseignements d'intérêt pour
la commission d'abord les femmes avaient
effectivement été moins exposées que les
hommes à des cancérogènes professionnels
toutefois une proportion non négligeable
de patiente avait bel et bien été
exposée et même multi-exposé au cours de
leur parcours et même à certains postes
de travail multi exposés également
elle présentait d'ailleurs certains
profils spécifiques de multi-exposition
retrouver à l'occasion de situations
souvent moins faciles à repérer en lien
avec les postes et les tâches
spécifiques effectués dans leur travail
pour exemple nous allons retrouver une
combinaison d'exposition à des agents
biologiques et à des polluants
organiques qui ont été notamment liées à
des activités de soins mais aussi des
activités de nettoyage dans lesquelles
les femmes sont beaucoup plus
représentées que les hommes
ces profils s'inscrivaient en outre dans
des parcours ou des carrières plus
hachées ne le ne leur permettant pas de
cumuler les durées ou les intensités
requises par le système de réparation
des maladies professionnelles fondées
sur les tableaux de maladies
professionnelles
s'en suivez d'une part une moindre
proportion de femmes éligibles à une
déclaration en maladie professionnelle
parmi les patientes exposées et d'autre
part à une moindre reconnaissance en
maladie professionnelle parmi celles
ayant voulu recourir à ce droit
impliquant en particulier une absence
d'indemnisation de ces attentes à la
santé liées au travail
à ce sujet il convient de rappeler que
les statistiques sur les accidents du
travail et les maladies professionnelles
dites statistiques de sinistralité
reflètent d'une part uniquement les
travailleuses et travailleurs qui sont
couverts par ce régime d'assurance
sociale dans son notamment exclus les
indépendants et indépendants et dont les
ATMP sont par ailleurs enregistrés dans
un système d'information nationale ADOX
qui n'est pas le cas encore aujourd'hui
pour les fonctionnaires d'État qui ne
sont pas couverts dans ces statistiques
et d'autre part et concerne uniquement
les accidents du travail et les maladies
professionnelles indemnisées on peut
donc tout au plus se baser sur ces
statistiques pour rendre compte des
écarts notamment entre hommes et femmes
dans l'accès aux droits à réparation et
non pas pour poser un diagnostic complet
sur la nature et l'étendue des attentes
à la santé liées au travail parmi
l'ensemble des actifs et actives et
anciens actives et actifs
la référence implicite suivie en santé
au travail mais aussi dans les
connaissances scientifiques produites
par l'épidémiologie a ainsi longtemps
été celle d'un travailleur masculin dans
le genre était réputé neutre résultat
les pratiques de prévention ont été plus
faibles et moins efficaces pour les
travailleurs et le modèle de réparation
fondé sur les tableaux de maladies
professionnelles suisses cette même
logique or comment attribuer une maladie
à une seule exposition devant du coup
être massive pour pouvoir compter
lorsque la réalité du travail a été de
cumuler des expositions diverses et de
plus faibles durée ou intensité au sein
de parcours de plus en plus mouvants
pour partie précarisés
sur cette question des parcours
professionnels et des types de
participation à l'emploi constance
beau-fils a des éclairages précis à vos
apportés quant à la place et au rôle
ambigu de l'inactivité sur la santé des
femmes aux âges âgées où âges élevés
excusez-moi merci pour votre attention
bonjour et merci pour l'invitation donc
je compte aujourd'hui vous présenter
certains résultats de mon travail de
thèse et notamment les directions quel
point en terme de santé publique en ce
qui concerne les carrières à risque pour
la santé donc ma thèse elle étudiait
comment les interruptions de carrière
féminine souvent liées aux maternité
était lié à leur santé plus tard dans la
vie aux âges du vieillissement elle
partait du constat en dépit de la
féminisation du marché du travail dans
les années 1960 l'inactivité
professionnelle continue de marquer les
parcours de vie des femmes ce sont
toujours quasi exclusivement des femmes
qui réduisent leur temps de travail ou
qui sortent de l'emploi au moment des
maternités et l'inactivité
professionnelle reste très fréquente
dans certaines configurations familiales
donc par exemple selon les données du
recensement 2019 20% des maires de trois
enfants ou plus sont en inactivité
professionnelle et ce chiffre montre à
monte à 40%, lorsque le plus jeune de
ses enfants a moins de 3 ans
donc ce constat il croisait celui des
inégalités de santé entre les hommes et
les femmes et celui de la spécificité
surtout des formes de la mauvaise santé
féminine
Osage du vieillissement donc on sait que
les femmes vivent plus longtemps que les
hommes mais elles passent plus d'années
avec des incapacités et avec des
symptômes dépressifs donc leurs années
supplémentaires sont des années ont
mauvaises santé je me suis alors demandé
comment ces périodes d'inactivité
professionnelle qui marque les carrières
féminines étaient reliées à leur chance
de vivre en bonne ou en mauvaise santé
pour répondre à ces questions j'ai
utilisé les données de l'Enquête Santé
itinéraire professionnelle de l'INSEE et
les données de la courte épidémiologique
constance qui comporte 200 000 individus
recrutés entre 2012 et 2017 ensuite à
partir d'analyse statistiques j'ai pu
identifier des parcours critiques pour
leur vieillissement en d'autres termes
j'ai pu identifier pour qui et dans quel
cas des interruptions de carrière sont
liées à des problèmes de santé plus tard
j'ai ensuite réalisé des entretiens
biographiques auprès de 30 femmes âgées
de plus de 50 ans et passés par
l'inactivité qui m'ont permis de
comprendre les processus situés derrière
ces parcours critiques donc finalement
par ces analyses et identifier trois
marqueurs des parcours de vie féminin
par lesquels des inégalités de santé se
forment et sur lesquels des politiques
publiques pour réagir ce sont ces
résultats là que je voudrais partager
avec vous aujourd'hui donc tout d'abord
que les femmes interrompent ou non leur
emploi des conditions de travail
délétères des emplois précaires
précaires et instables et des difficult
articulé les rôles familiaux et
professionnels sont associés à des
problèmes de santé
Osage élevés donc globalement combiner
maternité et emploie tout au long du
parcours de vie il y a une meilleure
santé les mères qui ont été toujours en
emploi entre 18 et 50 ans que ce soit à
temps partiel ou à temps plein déclare
plus tard une meilleure santé perçue
mentale et fonctionnelle que celle qui
ont interrompu leur emploi ces bénéfices
en termes de santé concernent aussi les
femmes séparées où sont conjoint ces
résultats diffèrent donc en partie de ce
observer au Royaume-Uni aux États-Unis
et semble attester d'une articulation
famille travail globalement facilité par
les politiques familiales et sociales
françaises toutefois dans certains cas
rester en emploi semble tout de même
liés à des risques de santé mentale
notamment on a identifié un cas de
femmes qui sont devenus maire autour de
24 ans soit un âge à peu près un médian
intermédiaire pour ces générations là et
ces femmes elles ont aussi passé du
temps en en charge d'enfants en bas âge
et celle-ci donc présente des risques
accrus d'anxiété plus tard cela suggère
que faire durablement face à des
conflits familles travail à un moment de
la carrière où se joue potentiellement
l'avancement professionnel expose à des
tensions qui se manifeste par des
troubles anxieux plus tard aux âges du
vieillissement des politiques qui
réduisent des tensions famille travail à
ces périodes critiques de la carrière
pourrait donc réduire des risques de
vieillissement en mauvaise santé pour
certains groupes de femmes en outre mes
résultats montrent que les trajectoires
d'emploi qu'elles soient ou non
interrompues sont liés à des risques de
santé fonctionnelle et perçu aux âges
élevés lorsqu'elles sont composées de
période d'emploi instable de période
d'emploi précaires et lorsqu'elles sont
marquées par des expositions
professionnelles
pour rappel les données de la DARES
montrent que les femmes ça recoupent en
partie jusqu'à dit Madame kunil mais les
femmes donc sont particulièrement
exposées au risque psychosociaux et aux
contraintes organisationsnelles beaucoup
plus que les hommes elles sont aussi
très concernées dans certaines
professions de la santé et des services
aux particuliers par les contraintes
physique lourdes ou les expositions
chimiques donc si à l'échelle de la
population active elles le sont moins
que les hommes exposés à ces contraintes
physiques lourdes à ses expositions
chimiques c'est surtout en raison de la
distribution des emplois donc les femmes
sont sous représentées dans le secteur
secondaire où se trouve les professions
aux pénibilité fortes qui sont bien
identifiés dans les griffes de mesure
les femmes sont aussi souvent confrontés
à des contraintes physiques
particulières comme les gestes
répétitifs et cadencés qui sont associés
aux troubles musculo-squelettiques
ces conditions de travail délétères
concernent d'autant plus les femmes
qu'elles connaissent moins de promotion
notamment en lien avec l'inactivité
professionnelle et reste donc plus
longtemps dans des emplois exposés
ensuite en deuxième résultat qui ressort
dans ma thèse c'est que des obstacles
anticipés ou effectivement rencontrés au
retour en emploi peuvent enfermer les
femmes qui ont interrompu leur carrière
dans des trappes à inactivité et ces
trappes accompagnent plus tard des
symptômes dépressifs donc en effet les
femmes qui ont connu des sorties
définitives d'emploi à des âges précoces
autour de la maternité
présente en général une moins bonne
santé mentale aux AGV que celles qui ont
connu une carrière continue elle déclare
plus souvent un épisode dépressif majeur
et des consommations de psychotropes en
fait les récides vie que j'ai recueilli
montrent que ces trajectoires traduisent
pour l'ensemble des femmes une trappe à
une activité c'est à dire qu'elle
manifeste des difficultés vécues ou
anticipées à se réinsérer sur le marché
du travail sans subir un des classements
professionnels ou en exerçant un emploi
avec des conditions de travail
compatibles avec leurs santé puisque
elles retournent plus tard sur le marché
du travail avec un nom un état de santé
qui s'est potentiellement dégradé
à une activité ce que j'observe c'est
qu'elle concerne l'ensemble des femmes
quel que soit leur niveau de diplôme ou
de qualification les plus qualifiés
perçoivent une impossibilité à
réintégrer leur métier antérieur souvent
en raison des évolutions de ces métiers
et parce qu'elle pense et considère
avoir perdu leur compétences elle pense
qu'il leur est impossible de retourner
sur le marché du travail donc sans subir
un des classements professionnels les
moins qualifiés perçoivent aussi une
impossibilité à réintégrer leur métier
antérieur mais en plus de ça elles sont
parfois contraintes économiquement de
reprendre un emploi et tant échoue alors
à plusieurs reprises de revenir sur le
marché du travail puisque les emplois
qu'elle réintègrent sont plus souvent
précaires ou incompatibles avec leur
santé
ainsi des politiques publiques qui
favorisent les retours en emploi des
femmes sont nécessaires pour que
celles-ci évite de tomber dans ses
trappes qui semble critique pour leur
santé mentale plus tard dans la vie
enfin un autre résultat est que certains
événements biographiques comme une
séparation conjugale par exemple mettre
en péril l'équilibre économique des
femmes éloignées de l'emploi et donc
infiner leur santé donc je m'explique
mes résultats montrent des cas ou des
interruptions longues ne sont pas liées
à des problèmes de santé aux ages élevés
par exemple pour les femmes plus
diplômées ou dont le conjoint est cadre
les interruptions longues ou définitives
ne sont pas toujours liées à des
problèmes de santé plus tard dans la vie
en fait les conséquences économiques de
ces interruptions sont pour ces femmes
réduites soit par leur patrimoine soit
par le revenu de leur conjoint et les
conséquences de l'inactivité en termes
d'identité sociale peuvent être amortis
par les nombreux loisirs loisirs et
engagement associatifs de ces femmes
toutefois mes résultats montrent que cet
équilibre des femmes en inactivité
professionnelle et fragile et peut-être
remise en cause par des événements comme
des séparations ou par exemple un
accident lié à la situation
professionnelle de leur conjoint en
effet j'observe dans ma thèse que
l'absence de conjoint aux âges élevés
accentuent les risques de mauvaise santé
mentale porter par une longue période
d'inactivité professionnelle passée en
fait elle absence de conjoint contraint
les femmes qui ont interrompu leur
carrière à se maintenir en emploi coûte
que coûte aux acheteurs elles ont moins
de marge de manœuvre pour réduire leur
temps de travail ou partir en retraite
plus tôt lorsque les conditions
d'exercice de leur emploi sont
incompatibles avec leur santé et elles
ont moins de marge de manœuvre parce
qu'elles n'ont pas suffisamment cotisées
aussi pour les femmes en couple avec un
ouvrier les trajectoires de sortie
définitive ou les interruptions longues
sont liées à encore plus de risques de
mauvaise santé mentale plus tard en fait
pour elle l'inactivité professionnelle
amène une dépendance économique
vis-à-vis du revenu de leur conjoint or
les ouvriers sont plus susceptibles de
connaître des accidents de travail ou
des arrêts maladie dès lors pour ces
femmes l'inactivité professionnelle
de sécurité économique et fait courir le
risque d'épisodes de difficultés
économiques importants et récurrent
épisode qu'on sait lié à la santé des
individus donc dans la mesure où ces
événements qui catalysent les risques
liés aux périodes d'inactivité
professionnelles tant à devenir plus
fréquent comme les séparations
conjugales encourager le maintien des
femmes en emploi constituerait une
politique de santé publique ceci
pourrait passer par la réduction des
contraintes des contraintes qui
l'empêchent soit d'après la littérature
les contraintes liées à l'organisation
du travail au mode de garde à la
disponibilité du conjoint et à la
répartition du travail au sein du foyer
ainsi pour conclure ma thèse montre que
les interruptions d'emplois des femmes
au cours de leur carrière constituent
des enjeux de santé publique par les
trappes à une activité professionnelle
sur lesquelles elles peuvent déboucher
et par les risques dont elles sont
porteuses en cas de séparation ou
d'accidents liés à la situation d'emploi
du conjoint les expositions
professionnelles les conditions d'emploi
précaires et les tensions famille
travaille à des moments charnières de la
carrière sont d'autres leviers qui
ressortent comme cruciaux pour réduire
les inégalités de santé aux âges élevées
et dont les risques peuvent se cumuler
avec ceux liés aux interruptions
d'emploi j'espère que mon propos a été
clair et je me tiens à votre disposition
pour donner plus de précisions ou
d'informations
et bien merci mesdames pour ces propos
qui déjà nous éclairent sur
différents sujets à la fois
l'organisation du temps de travail les
contraintes l'identification de la
pénibilité du travail aussi on le voit à
travers on le ressent à travers vos
propos il y a pas forcément
on sait pas toujours intéressé à la
santé des femmes au travail on s'y
intéressé aussi différemment de la santé
des hommes au travail parce qu'il y
avait cette visibilité qui n'était pas
la même aussi donc je vais j'imagine
laisser la parole aux rapporteur parce
que le sujet est
d'importance on aborde je l'ai dit dans
mon propos liminaire le sujet des
retraites et forcément tout ce que vous
venez de dire fait écho aussi à ce
parcours de travail et de retraite
possible à l'issue donc je ne sais pas
qui souhaitent prendre la parole de nos
trois rapporteurs présents Laurence
Cohen on va démarrer par Laurence Cohen
bonjour Merci beaucoup mesdames pour vos
propos introductifs oui moi j'ai un
certain quelques questions à vous poser
parce que il y a des données que vous
nous avez livré ce matin qui en tout cas
moi mon
interrogé j'aimerais avoir plus
d'éléments sur le sujet vous avez
beaucoup insisté me semble-t-il en tout
cas moi c'est ce que j'ai retenu sur les
conséquences des différents tensions au
travail et ou périodes d'inactivité
par rapport à la à la santé mentale et
vous avez beaucoup moins insisté sur
les les troubles qui peut y avoir
musculo-squelettiques ou autres accident
du travail puisqu'on sait par exemple
que les au niveau de des accidents du
travail il y a une égalité entre les
travailleurs parce que je peux dire
travailleurs parce qu'ils sont vraiment
très majoritaires dans le bâtiment et
les aides à domicile par exemple donc
vous n'avez pas du tout abordé la
question donc je voudrais avoir
peut-être plus d'éléments est-ce que
c'est un parti pris ou est-ce que c'est
effectivement par rapport aux données
que vous avez pu recueillir on sait que
les risques psychosociaux
quand on y quand on s'y pense bien il y
a 31% des femmes qui sont en situation
de tension
au travail contre 27% des hommes donc ça
peut expliquer en partie mais pas que
donc j'aimerais avoir votre votre
sentiment là-dessus deuxième élément
vous n'avez pas du tout abordé par
rapport justement aux conséquences qui
pourraient y avoir plus tard au niveau
psychique les violences sexuelles et
sexistes que subissent les femmes au
travail et qui restent quand même
beaucoup encore
un tabou voir qui sont déniés au niveau
d'un certain nombre d'entreprises donc
où on voit que quand les femmes
subissent ce genre d'agression et bien
c'est souvent elle qui doivent quitter
et quand je dis souvent c'est vraiment
très très majoritaire qui doivent
quitter l'entreprise et pas pas
l'agresseur donc là aussi j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi en fait vous n'avez pas
abordé particulièrement cette question
et quand vous parlez donc de de la
différence c'est très intéressant quand
vous dites en fait les femmes qui ont pu
qui ont eu des enfants qui ont continué
leur carrière professionnelle au moins
de de problèmes de santé que celles qui
ont interrompu pendant un temps
important mais là encore je pense qu'il
y a alors vous l'avez dit un peu mais je
pense aussi il y a évidemment tout ce
qui se vit au niveau de du travail mais
il y a aussi tout l'environnement après
social économique auquel les femmes
doivent faire face dans leur vie dans
leur vie personnelle vous l'avez un
petit peu abordé me semble-t-il à la fin
mais là peut-être aussi avoir plus
d'éléments et la toute dernière question
je suis désolé j'en pose beaucoup mais
c'est vrai que ça m'a j'ai été très
intéressant en fait donc on peut
vraiment on peut on peut dire de manière
très précise que il y a pas un déficit
de recherche
au niveau justement de de de de comment
dirais-je de la santé des femmes au
travail c'est-à-dire il y a eu des
chercheuses qui ont beaucoup travaillé
donc les travaux sont là
moi je m'interroge si hier j'étais sur
Public Sénat et ce qui ressortait quand
même dans dans avec les interlocutrices
qui étaient présentes justement les
interlocutrices c'est à dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de de travaux de recherche il y
a beaucoup de chercheuses mais ça n'a
pas l'air d'intéresser
l'ensemble de la société s'intéresse
exclusivement éventuellement les femmes
mais pas pas plus pas au delà désolé mon
cher collègue il y a d'exception et si
on veut si on veut si on veut arriver à
faire des progrès il faut que ce soit
toute la société qui se sentent
concernés voilà désolé j'étais un peu
longue mais ça m'a ça m'a beaucoup
interrogé merci en tout cas merci Madame
la rapporteur pour ses premières
questions c'est vrai que on se regardait
au moment de votre exposé et il y a des
choses qui nous interpellent et je vais
compléter peut-être et vous laisser
répondre à cette première série de
questions sur la santé des femmes au
travail qui serait meilleur que la santé
des femmes qu'il n'aurait pas travaillé
donc est-ce que vous pouvez préciser la
question qui était posée par Laurence
Cohen est-ce que c'est parce qu'il y a
meilleur suivi lorsque les femmes
travaillent avec
la médecine du travail est-ce que c'est
parce qu'elle développe non mais c'est
une question
une question ouverte je vais pas du
jugement pour le moment est-ce que
est-ce que c'est lié à des à des choses
qu'elle développe parce qu'elle ne
travaille pas la sédentarité etc c'est
quoi les motifs de cette différence de
santé merci
je vais commencer par répondre à toutes
ces questions vis-à-vis de l'inactivité
j'ai commencé par répondre à la dernière
parce que je pense que ça permet de
précisé mon propos donc en fait il y a
plusieurs mécanismes qui sont
susceptibles de lier les interruptions à
la santé et c'est ce qui fait qu'au
début j'avais du mal à anticiper les
résultats que j'obtiendrai par mes
analystes statistiques en fait
l'inactivité professionnelle elle peut
être néfaste pour la santé des femmes
par ses conséquences sur leurs
ressources économiques sociales et aussi
symbolique donc effectivement
l'inactivité amène en manque à gagner à
l'instant T mais aussi à la retraite et
donc on sait que les inégalités
économiques des bouchent directement sur
des inégalités de santé les inégalités
sociales de santé donc il y a surtout un
mécanisme économique qui fait que tout
simplement les femmes qui sont passées
par l'inactivité professionnelle font
plus face à des risques de difficultés
économiques qui débouchent ensuite sur
de la mauvaise santé ensuite il était
aussi dit que l'inactivité
professionnelle effectivement pouvait
mener à l'isolement social donc ça je
l'ai pas retrouvé parce que j'ai trouvé
que les femmes qui sont pas en emploi
s'engagent parfois dans des associations
ont des réseaux d'amis qui parfois ont
la même situation d'emploi qu'elle donc
c'est quelque chose que j'ai pas
retrouvé en revanche qui est très fort
et qui ressort énormément c'est le
stigmate lié à l'inactivité
professionnelle et donc c'est ça qui est
au centre de mon argument pour relier la
santé mentale avec ces périodes
d'inactivité professionnelle donc la
plupart des toutes les femmes qu'elles
soient non qualifiées très qualifiée
très diplômés peu diplômés quel que soit
donc leur position sociale
rapporte et décrivent des remarques ou
des jugements vis-à-vis de leur
situation d'emploi et une partie d'entre
elles disent avoir honte et avoir
parfois caché leur situation d'emploi
donc c'est par ces mécanismes là à la
fois économiques et symbolique que
j'interprète c'est risque de santé dont
son porteuse les interruptions de
effectivement autre chose que anticipais
c'était que l'inactivité professionnelle
aurait pu protéger la santé des femmes
des risques liés aux expositions
professionnelles
toutefois on peut aussi se dire que la
sphère domestique n'est pas épargné par
ces expositions professionnelles c'est
juste qu'on les mesure pas donc
effectivement il n'y a aucune enquête
qui permette de documenter des
expositions des pénibilités auxquelles
les femmes feraient face dans la sphère
privée donc on a des enquêtes conditions
de travail mais qui sont qui
s'appliquent seulement pour les employés
on peut toutefois imaginer que si on
reproduisait cette enquête condition de
travail pour les femmes qui ne sont pas
en emploi on trouverait aussi des
sources de pénibilité et d'exposition
dans la sphère domestique et donc on
sait bien qu'il y a mais je n'ai pas les
chiffres particulier des expositions des
accidents du travail dans la sphère
domestique liée à l'exécution de tâches
parentales et domestiques
donc voilà pour la dernière question
en ce qui concerne les liens avec la
santé mentale c'est surtout une question
de données effectivement donc moi j'ai
observé trois indicateurs de santé qui
sont des indicateurs généraux déclarés
par les femmes elles-mêmes ces
indicateurs c'est la mauvaise santé
perçue donc c'est une question où on
demande aux femmes si elles jusque leur
état de santé est bon et très bon bon
moyen mauvais ou très mauvais en général
donc ça peut sembler être en indicateur
très subjectif et peu fiable mais il se
trouve que c'est l'indicateur qui est
l'un des indicateurs les plus corrélés à
la mortalité plus tard donc en fait
c'est un assez bon indicateur qui
documente à la fois la santé physique et
mentale puisque les gens intègrent ces
deux dimensions lorsqu'ils évaluent leur
état de santé perçu et ensuite j'ai
utilisé un indicateur de symptômes
dépressifs et un dernier indicateur de
limitation d'activité donc les
limitations d'activités on demande aux
femmes si dans leur activité quotidienne
elle elles sont empêchées pour réaliser
voilà des tâches du quotidien
et je n'ai pas trouvé de lien
significatifs entre interruption
d'emplois et santé fonctionnelle ou
santé perçu mais seulement entre les
interruptions d'emploi et la santé
mentale toutefois je tiens à le rappeler
parce que c'était peut-être pas assez
souligné mais tout ce qui est
instabilité de l'emploi précarité donc
ils sont d'autres dimensions cruciales
et marquantes de la carrière ou encore
les expositions professionnelles tout ça
est lié à la santé perçue qui intègre
donc tout un tas d'éléments de la santé
physique et aussi à la santé
fonctionnelle
ensuite en ce qui concerne les violences
sexuelles sur les lieux de travail
effectivement c'est une très bonne
remarque tout simplement je ne l'a pas
enfin je ne l'avais pas aussi dans mes
données donc je ne pouvais pas forcément
l'intégrer dans mes analyses mais ça
peut enfin cette dimension des violences
sexuelles je les retrouvais dans mes
entretiens et je les retrouvais
notamment dans la sphère privée pour des
éléments d'espoir privé donc c'est aussi
un argument qui peut expliquer la
mauvaise santé parfois des femmes en
inactivité professionnelle qui est
qu'elles sont plus souvent exposées et
plus vulnérables face aux violences
sexuelles et aux violences conjugales
dans la sphère privée
voilà je sais pas si j'ai répondu à tout
peut-être Émilie tu as des éléments pour
compléter notamment en ce qui concerne
le déficit de recherche par rapport
alors ouais d'abord donc donc
effectivement je vais commencer par ça
sur le déficit de recherche je n'ai pas
dit qu'il y avait pas de déficit de
recherche en fait j'ai dit qu'il fallait
bien distinguer les champs
disciplinaires et même à l'intérieur des
disciplines les voilà les sous
disciplines on va dire les champs de
spécialisation c'est à dire que les
sciences sociales se sont emparées de la
question de la santé au travail des
femmes depuis longtemps ça n'a pas été
le cas des sciences biomédicales donc je
faisais vraiment
un peu une opposition un peu
caricaturale mais entre disons oui
sociologie et épidémiologie typiquement
puisque en tant épidémiologie j'ai été
confronté à voilà à voir que mon regard
très très forgé par un apprentissage de
la biologie de la physique-chimie des
mathématiques etc
a été amené à changer au contact de mes
collègues en sciences humaines et
sociales qui avaient pensé les questions
de genre les différents sommes femmes
au-delà du biologique
donc il y a quand même encore il me
semble beaucoup de choses à faire mais
il y a aussi beaucoup de connaissances
acquises et donc effectivement je vous
rejoins sur le fait que peut-être
l'enjeu c'est de les rendre visible déjà
ses connaissances qui existent même si
c'est toujours important de travailler
sur les points aveugles et de continuer
à progresser mais de rendre visible ses
connaissances et d'attirer l'attention
vous soulignez que elle elle intéresse
peu de monde faut quand même enfin je là
je veux pas être démesurément optimiste
mais il y a quand même eu notamment dans
la loi pour l'égalité des hommes et des
femmes enfin des femmes et des hommes
du 4 août 2014 introduit une obligation
finalement de faire une évaluation genre
des conditions de travail des risques
professionnels donc
la loi existe on va dire ensuite en
termes d'outils pour le faire la nacte
l'Agence nationale pour l'amélioration
des conditions de travail à proposer dès
le milieu des années 2010 je pense
c'était peut-être en 2014 peut-être un
peu plus tard un guide justement pour
penser l'égalité homme-femme y compris
en termes de conditions de travail et de
conditions de rémunération et de
carrière tout ensemble dans les
diagnostics portés au sein des
entreprises alors à quel point ces
démarches sont mises en oeuvre je n'ai
pas les données pour vous le dire je
pense que vous devez avoir des sources
pour le pour le regarder mais en tout
cas voilà il y a déjà beaucoup de choses
qu'on connaît là pareil statistiques
nationales aussi donc fournit des
données intéressantes qui peuvent être
exploitées les résultats ne sont pas
toujours systématiquement présentés par
sexe on va dire ou par genre mais de
plus en plus quand même donc toutes les
enquêtes conduites de manière récurrente
par le ministère du travail comme
l'enquête conditions de travail et
l'enquête Summaire surveillance médicale
de l'exposition riche professionnelle
évidemment recueille les informations
socio-démographiques
cruciales et peuvent être exploités sous
cet angle il y a eu des exploitations
sous cet angle qui permettent notamment
de connaître les problèmes généraux
auxquels sont confrontées les femmes en
termes de santé au travail et de
conditions de travail et notamment de
montrer qu'il y a pas seulement de
l'usure psychique mais aussi de l'usure
physique ça a été dit à la ségrégation
sexuée du travail et des tâches même au
sein de même poste qui ont eu tendance à
attribuer les femmes enfin les affecter
à des tâches dites plus fines
considérées peut-être comme plus légère
mais finalement qui par leur répétition
par leur rythme par les contraintes
temporelles dans lesquelles elles sont
effectuées peuvent être également très
usantes alors que les hommes ont
peut-être dans certains secteurs
bénéficier davantage d'une
automatisation qui les rendait plus chef
opérateur d'une machine que devant
eux-mêmes faire face à des pénibilités
physiques
donc voilà donc et pour revenir sur le
déficit de recherche bien entendu il y a
un déficit de toujours même sur le plan
de la santé des femmes et des hommes on
a des déficits genre et de connaissances
simplement sur la santé même au-delà du
travail mais ça je pense que vous
auditions l'ont bien montré
l'ostéoporose chez les hommes c'est pas
encore vrai un sujet de recherche
l'infarctus du myocar chez les femmes il
y a eu beaucoup d'attention portée
dessus notamment à cause de déficit de
reconnaissance à l'arrivée aux urgences
et des conséquences que ça avait pour la
survie des femmes et donc ça a été de
cette mieux en mieux connu mais
néanmoins il y a toujours des projets à
faire parce que les stéréotypes ont la
peau dure sur quels sont les problèmes
de santé des femmes et des hommes et
quels sont les mécanismes par lesquels
c'est ces problèmes de santé surviennent
donc ça c'était sur le déficit de
connaissance peut-être je pense que
Constance beau-fils a déjà beaucoup
donné d'éléments sur sur les autres
questions je voudrais souligner par
rapport enfin redire que quelque chose
que Constance a dit qui est très
important c'est c'est que finalement
quand on regarde ces questions activité
d'inactivité et de et de santé bien sûr
on est toujours face à ce qu'on appelle
nous en épidémiologie l'effet
travailleurs sain ou travailleuse saine
c'est à dire que pour travailler il faut
être insuffisamment bonne santé donc ça
c'est des choses dont bien sûr les
travaux de recherche tiennent compte
pour bien dégager les faits on va dire
propre de être inactif en tant que tel
ou inactive et pourquoi finalement on a
été en amont amené à prendre des perles
d'inactivité et c'est pas seulement lié
bien sûr au fait d'être d'une femme qui
devient mère avec des tâches familiales
qui se qui s'ajoutent ça peut être aussi
lié à la santé
mais il y a aussi cette question du
cumul des temps et l'articulation des
temps professionnels et et personnel ou
familiaux et donc des cumuls des tâches
et des expositions liées au travail
productif et au travail des
non-productifs ou domestiques et
familiales ou au travail des reproductif
donc il y a effectivement des
expositions y compris chimiques dans les
activités de nettoyage domestique
quotidienne que les femmes continuent à
effectuer davantage que les hommes qui
peuvent se cumuler à des expositions
chimiques de même nature dans le travail
et peut-être pourrait-on aller jusqu'à
dire que plus les femmes ont ce genre
d'activité dans leur travail quotidien
plus ça va être facile dans le couple de
les assigner de nouveau à ces mêmes
tâches dans le dans le cadre domestique
insister aussi sur ce qui réinsister sur
sur ce qu'a dit constance déjà sur
l'importance pour les femmes qui ont eu
des parcours marqués quand même
majoritairement par de l'emploi même si
il peut y avoir des portes
d'interruption sur l'importance de
l'instabilité la précarité
donc de tout ce qui va faire des
parcours des parcours moins gratifiants
à un moment donné et moins gratifiant au
moment de la retraite ça a beaucoup de
données montrent qu'il y a des impacts
sur la santé psychique mais aussi
fonctionnels
voilà donc là peut-être après si vous
avez des questions précises sur des
points précis on pourra rechercher mais
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
documentation disponibles sur ce
processus sur ces sujets et pour finir
donc sur la violence sexuelle et
violences sexuelles et sexistes alors
c'est un point très très important
effectivement y compris en santé au
travail pas seulement en tant que
facteur de mal-être au travail
directement bien entendu mais aussi en
tant que facteur d'empêchement pour
prendre en compte des conditions de
travail des femmes en parler et trouver
des solutions alors là je pense que
c'est plutôt l'ergonomie il me semble
qui est une discipline bien outillée
pour pour parler de ces questions alors
je vais je vais donner un exemple que
donne Karen Messing qui est une une
ergonome enfin americano canadienne qui
travaille depuis très longtemps sur les
questions de genre et santé au travail
qui donne un exemple parmi d'autres un
like beaucoup beaucoup de publications
et d'ouvrages que je vous encourage à
consulter je pourrais vous donner des
suggestions de lecture si vous en avez
besoin elle parle d'un exemple très
concret donc elle a elle a donc fait une
étude pour le coup qualitatif elle a
observé le travail réel des femmes il
s'agissait de technicienne travaillant
dans l'installation de dispositif de
communication à Montréal c'était un
milieu de travail qui était presque
exclusivement masculin il n'y avait que
cette femme sur plusieurs centaines de
salariés donc ces ergonomes ont
rencontré
ces femmes pour discuter de leur travail
au début elle ne comprenait pas le but
de l'échange puisque pour elle il n'y
avait pas de problème spécifique aux
femmes
mais au bout de deux heures elles ont
évoqué le problème des ceintures portant
les outils qu'elle trouvait très
inconfortables alors c'était dû au fait
que les femmes ont les hanches plus
évasées par rapport à la taille que les
hommes et les outils pesaient lourd sur
leur sur leur hanche
l'ergonome a du réflexe de leur proposer
une ceinture reposant sur les pôles avec
des croisillons sur la poitrine afin de
soulager les hanches mais elles ont crié
qu'on ne pouvait pas faire ça parce que
cela aurait mis leur sein en avant or
elle cherchait en permanence à faire
oublier qu'elles étaient des femmes ce
n'est qu'au bout de trois heures
d'échange qu'elles ont évoqué les vrais
affaires à savoir le harcèlement qu'elle
subissait de la part de leurs collègues
du contremaître et des clients elle va
ressenter une forme de honte et se
disait que si elles étaient harcelées
c'est qu'elle l'avait peut-être méritée
voilà mais est-ce qu'une femme doit être
identique à un homme pour être son égal
voilà bon c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres donc évidemment le fait d'avoir
pu parler entre femmes mais prendre ce
temps incompressible qui n'est pas celui
non plus d'une enquête statistique par
questionnaire qui a permis de faire
émerger finalement ce problème très
concret qui relie directement la
question du harcèlement sexuel à la
question de la prévention des risques
professionnels
bien merci à vous deux pour ces premiers
éléments de réponse qui ont été faites à
la suite aux intervention de Laurence
Cohen rapporteur peut-être je vais
passer la parole à une autre de nos
corps-à-porteurs mais vous demandez
aussi par la même occasion est-ce que
vous avez identifié des secteurs
d'activité différents parce que on parle
notamment de la santé des femmes au
travail notamment dans les les métiers
de la santé est-ce que vous avez
identifié des secteurs dans l'industrie
dans les professions libérales ce qui a
une différence entre la santé des femmes
au travail à travers les secteurs
d'activité dans lesquels elle se trouve
et je vous avais également interrogé
dans mon propos liminaire sur le travail
de nuit est-ce que vous avez des
références sur ces sujets là et je passe
tout de suite la parole à peut-être
Marie-Pierre Richier qui semble prête à
vous interroger merci merci
présidente merci mesdames pour pour
votre exposé et ça va me permettre de
rebondir parce que je l'avais noté
également effectivement il y a beaucoup
de secteurs qui ont été évoqués
également et puis bon c'est tout ce que
j'ai noté parce qu'on retrouve beaucoup
de sujets on s'aperçoit que la santé des
femmes au travail n'est pas qu'une
question de biologie c'est aussi une
question
sociétale sociale et sociétale et on
voit que ça revient quand même assez
assez en boucle et quelque part par
rapport à ce diagnostic que l'on entend
assez souvent quel serait les
préconisations
merci
merci chers collègues je vous laisse
répondre ensuite on passera aux
questions de Annick jacquemais peut-être
la grapporteur troisième rapporteur je
voulais vous organiser comme vous le
souhaitez je vais commencer avec la
mobilité professionnelle non d'abord en
fonction de la taille des entreprises
alors j'ai plus exactement les
références mais je pourrais vous les
communiquer il y a quelques études
notamment j'ai en tête qui ont étudié
les difficultés
d'articuler les rôles de femmes en
emploi et de mère en fonction des
entreprises et qui montre effectivement
que c'est souvent plus facile dans les
ordres entre dans les grandes
entreprises parce qu'il y a plus de
dispositifs de politique de garde mise
en place dans ces entreprises là Emilie
pourra peut-être compléter mon propos en
ce qui concerne les dispositifs de
réparation au travail mais mais je pense
que c'est à peu près la même chose en
termes de dispositif de santé au travail
ceux-ci sont plus présents quand les
entreprises sont plus importantes en
termes de taille
ensuite je voudrais aussi ajouter oui
en terme
je pense que les deux sont liés aussi
c'était là aussi ma question par rapport
au secteur d'activité et à l'entreprise
à la
l'importance de l'entreprise en fonction
aussi du nombre de femmes qui sont dans
les secteurs pour moi les deux je pense
que les chiffres seraient intéressant
alors j'ai pas exactement en tête les
chiffres mais j'ai effectivement je
pourrais retrouver cet article et le
communiqué à la délégation si nécessaire
et oui une autre parenthèse qui rejoint
en fait qu'a dit Émilie sur est-ce que
ça intéresse les gens la santé des
femmes au travail en ce qui concerne
l'inactivité en tout cas ça ça a très
peu intéressé les gens il y a très très
peu d'études là dessus sur les liens
entre interruption de carrière et santé
ce qui est d'autant plus surprenant que
les femmes qui sont en inactivité
professionnelle en lien avec leur
trajectoire familiale sont très
nombreuses comme je l'ai dit dans mon
propos introductif donc en tout cas moi
en ce qui me concerne c'est vrai que
j'ai un peu bataillé pour trouver des
données là-dessus et je pense que ça
commence à venir mais effectivement
on n'a pas tant d'éléments que ça sur
les liens entre ces carrières hachées et
la santé alors même que c'est très
intéressant notamment en termes de santé
au travail puisque comme je l'ai
expliqué le fait d'avoir des carrières
hachées
fait qu'ensuite on va avoir une carrière
moins souvent ascendante fait qu'on va
pour rester plus longtemps au même poste
et donc on va être exposé plus
durablement à des contraintes physiques
à des risques psychosociaux à des
expositions chimiques biologiques enfin
bref à des conditions de travail
délétères dans tout leur éventail
ensuite en ce qui concerne la mobilité
professionnelle votre question c'était
par rapport au retour en emploi
au fait je crois que c'est une des
personnes qu'on devait auditionner qui a
étudié la mobilité professionnelle
notamment en ce qui concerne le
personnel navigant et qui montrait que
c'était beaucoup plus oui beaucoup plus
compliqué cette mobilité dans le dans le
temps justement avec l'articulation
famille couple ça se faisait souvent
détriment et donc au fur et à mesure
qu'on avançait dans l'âge c'était de
plus en plus compliqué pour accepter ces
mobilités
oui alors j'ai en tête aussi un travail
d'année Lambert écrit avec Delphine
rémillon qui porte aussi sur les
personnels navigants où elle montre que
la disponibilité biographique des femmes
ce qu'elles appellent en fait c'est le
fait de devoir est disponible pour ses
enfants pour les tâches domestiques
limite leur possibilité ensuite de
mobilité professionnelle ascendante
parce que tout simplement notamment dans
le dans l'entreprise qu'elles étudient
il y a un système de mobilité au choix
qui a été mis en place et qui fait que
donc la moitié une part des mobilités
professionnelles de l'entreprise en
question c'est ça se fait en fonction de
l'ancienneté mais il y a une part de ces
mobilités qui se font lorsque les
personnels navigants demandent eux-mêmes
une promotion et en fait ensuite ça va
être déterminé par les avis de leurs
équipes de leur supérieur etc et ce
qu'elle montre c'est qu'il est très
important notamment de passer au secteur
donc après un vol par exemple pour des
hôtesses de l'air de passer voir
l'équipe d'aller dans les bureaux etc et
ça va augmenter leur chance de mobilité
au choix puisqu'on suit elles vont être
désignées par leur supérieur ou ils vont
être désignés et donc en fait la
disponibilité biographique des femmes
elles empêchent ces stratégies de
promotion là et ça les expose donc à des
carrières moins souvent ascendantes donc
c'est ce qui explique que même comprend
compte le fait qu'elles sont plus
souvent à temps partiel plus souvent en
inactivité professionnelle elles ont
quand même des mobilités moins
importantes même si on prend un homme et
une femme qui ont eu le même la qui ont
la même ancienneté qui sont tous les
deux à temps plein et qui sont voilà qui
n'ont aucun des deux n'a connu
d'interruption professionnelle on a des
inégalités de carrière dans ces secteurs
là
en lien avec voilà les mécanismes même
de promotion au sein de ces secteurs
alors pour compléter les propos de
Constance beau-fils donc sur la question
des secteurs et des expositions donc
pour le coup l'appareil statistique
national permet de bien documenter la
ségrégation sexuée des emplois des
postes et aussi de bien voir les
différences de conditions de travail
donc on a notamment les enquêtes
conditions de travail qui sont
récurrentes et qui couvrent l'ensemble
des actifs contrairement à l'enquête
summer qui ne couvre pas les salariés
indépendants une partie de la fonction
publique
donc vous les avez cités déjà mais ce
qu'on se revoit bien sûr c'est que les
femmes sont particulièrement présentes
au sein des métiers de service avec les
métiers comme aide à domicile assistante
maternelle agent d'entretien mais aussi
la vente le commerce on en a beaucoup
parlé au moment du covid bien sûr les
caissières de supermarché et aussi bien
sûr dans les métiers du soin les
aides-soignantes les infirmières et les
sages-femmes tandis que les hommes sont
plus souvent conducteurs de véhicules
techniciens et agents de maîtrise de la
maintenance ouvrier qualifié de la
manutention et du second œuvre du
bâtiment enfin voilà on a des
statistiques on peut vous donner des
sources plus précis si vous voulez pour
voir les les distributions et bien sûr
ces différences de donc cette
ségrégation
on va dire horizontal du travail entre
hommes et femmes donc qui se distribuent
dans des secteurs et des types de
métiers différents explique bien sûr les
différences d'exposition professionnelle
avec davantage d'expositions pénibilité
physique chez les hommes quoi que les
femmes et quand même de l'usure physique
de différentes manières et bien sûr les
tâches représentant
une dimension émotionnelle une charge le
trade tout le travail émotionnel que les
femmes font déjà ou encore aujourd'hui
plus souvent au sein de la famille ou du
réseau social que les hommes se
retrouvent aussi dans l'assignation des
tâches dans le milieu de travail
donc ça il y a beaucoup de connaissances
je pourrais vous donner des des sources
sur les statistiques les plus récentes
la DARES fait des bilans sur les
conditions de travail qui permettent de
voir les différents hommes à ce sujet
sur la sur la question de la taille des
entreprises alors c'est une question
importante alors en épidémiologie qui
m'a discipline de départ c'est quelque
chose qu'on croit absolument pas en
compte parce qu'on ne demande pas aux
gens et aussi parce que
c'est vrai que dans cette approche
parcours de vie où on essaie de voir le
cumul finalement des des expositions et
des conditions de travail au cours de la
vie c'est compliqué de construire des
indicateurs cumulatifs de
type d'entreprises dans lesquelles les
personnes ont travaillé sauf quand les
carrières justement étaient très stables
avec un employeur principal etc donc
plus les carrières sont instables
hachés voilà avec des changements
d'emploi qui ont pu être choisis ou
subies plus on peut être face à des
changements aussi de
d'entreprises alors je suis d'accord
avec vous que la taille le profil
détails d'entreprise descend aussi des
secteurs mais quand même pas uniquement
ce que je peux dire c'est que en termes
de prévention donc bien entendu les PME
les PMI enfin les TPE même et elle est
très petite entreprise sont plus en
difficulté de manière générale pour pour
mettre en oeuvre les mesures de
prévention j'ai pas fait de travaux sur
la question mais c'est des choses qui
sont qui sont dessus et ça s'explique
bien mais il y a aussi le côté on va
dire légal de la chose qui est que donc
les anciens comités d'hygiène et de
sécurité au travail enfin sur les
conditions de travail étaient déjà
réserves aux entreprises de plus de 50
salariés on sait qu'il y a une
complexification du travail des
représentants du personnel avec la
fusion des instances représentatives
dans le CSE donc la question de la santé
au travail ne disparaît pas mais comme
elle est fusionnée avec plein d'autres
questions on se pose la question de quel
est le temps qui va pour être accordé à
la fois en termes de formation des
représentants du personnel et du temps
effectivement accordé à ces questions
dans le cadre de de des travaux de ces
comités
donc ça en termes de prévention bien
entendu sur les yeux même sur les
entreprises de plus grosses tailles se
posent la question mais les TPE a
fortiori et les TP qui ne disposent pas
forcément des mêmes outils sont plus en
difficulté donc il y a une attention
particulière à portée et
autre point ça serait percute aussi au
moment de la réparation aux maladies
professionnelles parce que on aboutir
que il y a présomption d'imputabilité
dans les tableaux de maladies
professionnelles et qui n'en a plus
besoin de faire la preuve qu'on a été
exposé dès lors qu'on remplit les
conditions des tableaux de maladies
professionnelles alors pour rappel un
tableau de maladie professionnelle vous
avez une colonne dénomine la maladie une
colonne qui dénomine le type
d'exposition professionnelle qui serait
éligible et ça va être typiquement par
exemple un agent chimique et puis vous
avez une colonne qui définit une liste
limitative ou indicative d'activité
professionnelle qu'il faut avoir
réalisé enfin dans laquelle il faut
avoir été actif pour pouvoir être
éligible avec des durées minimales aussi
d'exposition et donc ça quand même il
faut pouvoir faire la preuve de son
travail exposé quelque part quand on
fait une déclaration en maladie
professionnelle il faut quand même
prouver qu'on a travaillé dans une
entreprise à un poste de travail donné
donc faut fournir tous les relevés
tous les les tous les éléments de
connaissances de la carrière au delà de
ce que la CNAV par exemple peut fournir
en termes de reconstitution de carrière
donc il faut quand même faire la preuve
de son parcours professionnel et donc
lorsque l'entreprise a disparu ça peut
être plus difficile si on n'a pas gardé
au moment de la retraite ces bulletins
de salaire on a tout liquidé parce que
la CNAV nous a dit vous pouvez tout
liquider c'est bon c'est terminé sauf
qu'au moment de faire une déclaration
maladie professionnelle il faudrait
pouvoir les ressortir donc ça peut poser
des problèmes très auprès de
non-complétude des dossiers et puis
après lorsque
l'assurance maladie enquête fait son
enquête sur quand même pour voir s'il a
les critères d'éligibilités sont remplis
des entreprises normalement peuvent être
contactées pour avoir des informations
sur les conditions de travail lorsque
l'entreprise était de petites tailles à
la peu plus souvent changer de raison
sociale ou carrément avoir cessé son
activité et donc ça peut poser des
questions aussi de d'accès aux droits
parce que il sera plus difficile de
faire état des expositions qui ont été
rencontrées au cours du parcours
alors sur alors sur sur toujours alors
sur pour revenir sur volet prévention je
pense que l'enquête condition de travail
qui est couplée avec un volet salarié un
volet employeur peut apporter beaucoup
d'informations en couplant les deux
alors moi j'ai pas travaillé sur ces
données si ça vous intéresse pas
regarder s'il y a des éléments qui en
ont été tirés plus précisément
alors sur
[Musique]
sur le travail de nuit peut-être
première sur le travail de nuit c'est
intéressant parce que ça fait un pont
aussi avec les préconisations peut-être
donc alors je vais commencer par
préconisation très humblement parce que
je suis une chercheuse donc c'est pas
mon métier de faire des préconisations
en termes de politique publique
directement mais donc comme je l'ai
mentionné on a déjà des outils et une
obligation même de tenir compte des
différences entre mes femmes dans
l'évaluation des risques professionnels
donc j'ai envie de dire il y a qu'à le
insisté sur le fait que ça existe déjà
et qui a des outils pour le faire et
donc il faut absolument le faire donc
mieux former informer voilà
du coup ça fait le lien aussi avec
l'importance des mobilisations il faut
pas négliger le rôle des acteurs de la
société civile des représentants du
personnel et donc j'ai un exemple
justement autour du travail de nuit de
mobilisation
d'un syndicat à la CFDT qui depuis
l'année 2017 a commencé à s'intéresser
des cancers professionnels chez les
femmes alors c'est intéressant comme
dynamique en plus parce que c'est parti
d'un groupe de retraités du secteur
minier dans l'Est de la France qui a
connaissait très bien la question des
cancers professionnels pour avoir été
très fortement impactés et avoir
vraiment batailler pour faire
reconnaître les atteintes en matière de
cancer professionnelle et à leur
type cancer les retravail arrivé à la
retraite se rendre compte que toute
cette compétence accumulée toutes ces
connaissances
va finir par s'épuiser il continue à
recevoir des anciens travailleurs pour
les conseiller les accompagner mais
maintenant le secteur minier c'est
devenu le régime minier c'est de
Laurence est devenu essentiellement le
secteur sanitaire et social donc
majoritairement des femmes qui
travaillent dans ces secteurs beaucoup
plus jeunes que et qui n'ont pas la même
culture de la santé au travail en
particulier au terme de cancer
professionnelle et donc vient cette idée
en échangeant avec avec le secteur
sanitaire et social mais aussi les
personnels de bord des compagnies
aériennes que le cancer du sein ça
pourrait vraiment être un sujet
d'importance en termes de prévention et
de réparation puisque il y a un certain
nombre de facteurs de risques
professionnels qui sont connus comme le
travail de nuit même si il y a encore
une certaine
incertitude scientifique au niveau de la
solidité des preuves quand même le
Centre international de recherche sur le
cancer à confirmer que c'était un
cancerogène probable le travail de nuit
pour le cancer du sein et donc c'est
engagé toute une initiative avec y
compris en travaillant avec des
associations de femmes malades du cancer
du sein avec des voilà des courses et
des courses à vélo voilà beaucoup
d'opérations de communication là-dessus
et une enquête qu'ils ont conduite en
propre une enquête un peu dans le la
lignée des requêtes ouvrières pour
documenter les expositions des femmes au
travail dans ces secteurs là donc je
pense que les mobilisations sont très
importantes
et pour revenir sur la question du
travail de nuit je pense que bien sûr le
cancer du sein c'est un sujet mais il
faut pas oublier tous les effets déjà
très bien connus du travail de nuit sur
plein d'autres aspects de la santé
physique et mentale et cela il n'y a pas
besoin d'attendre qu'une énième étude de
l'Inserm qui était très très importante
cette étude d'ailleurs où de une enquête
internationale à soi de manière encore
plus ferme le lien entre travail de nuit
et cancer du sein avant le cancer du
sein ou en même temps que le cancer du
sein en tout cas il y a bien bien
d'autres effets et y compris sur des des
aspects de la vie qu'on peut considérer
d'habitude comme étant lié aux habitudes
de vie au comportement de santé mais les
habitudes alimentaires sont liées ces
établis avec les rythmes de travail et
donc les personnes qui travaillent de
nuit ont tendance à avoir une
alimentation moins saine moins
équilibrée parce qu'ils vivent sur des
rythmes sociaux décalés qui mangent plus
souvent seul que voilà donc bien sûr les
conditions de travail peuvent aussi
impacter les comportements de santé et
le travail de nuit en est un bon exemple
voilà alors sur le retour au travail
après cancer je pensais une question
très importante malheureusement c'est
pas mon domaine je sais qu'il y a des il
y a des recherches en cours qui sont
conduites en France et que même le la
recherche biomédicale sans saisie alors
bien sûr les recherches en épidémiologie
plutôt des risques professionnels
notamment en retour au travail après le
cancer du sein et les inégalités
sociales qui peut y avoir en matière de
retour à l'emploi j'ai pas de résultats
à vous communiquer mais je pourrais
regarder c'est quelque chose a déjà été
publié moi j'ai en tête un rapport il me
semble de Patrick Peretti Vatel sur la
ville 2 ans après ou quatre ans je sais
plus après le diagnostic d'un cancer
donc c'est un rapport très riche et très
fourni dans lequel vous trouverez
sûrement des éléments là dessus
et bien merci mesdames je vais laisser
la parole à Annick jacquemer apporteur
sur santé des femmes au travail merci
chers présidente merci mesdames pour
toutes les informations que vous nous
avez données mes collègues en japonais
pas mal de questions qui
m'interpellaient aussi donc j'ai eu en
partie les réponses
moi ce qui m'intéresserait de savoir
c'est je crois que
madame kunil vous nous avez parlé de
travaux qui date de 2010 si j'ai bien
bien retenu est-ce que vous pouvez faire
un comparatif entre j'allais dire la
génération d'avant et la génération
maintenant par rapport à justement la
répercussion de la de la santé pour les
femmes qui travaillent parce que je il
me semble qu'il y a une évolution aussi
j'allais dire demain ou une autre
génération avec la nouvelle génération
par rapport à au travail mais aussi par
rapport à la façon dont on envisage la
vie en général
je vous explique je suis frappée par la
jeune ou pas forcément mais les
trentenaires ou qui de plus en plus
ne veulent plus d'enfants
alors bon je sors peut-être un peu du
sujet mais malgré tout je trouve c'est
un ensemble la gestion du travail de la
vie familiale de tout l'environnement
est-ce que vous avez des données est-ce
que c'est
uniquement une angoisse de l'avenir
est-ce que c'est la difficulté de gérer
justement vie familiale
maternité et
carrière professionnelle parce que c'est
quelque chose qui m'interpelle beaucoup
et je voulais aussi savoir puisque
encore une fois dans ma génération je
connaissais quand même un certain nombre
de femmes qui ne travaillaient pas par
choix parce qu'elle voulait élever leurs
enfants et puis
et on entend plus ou je pense qu'on
entend plus maintenant ce je pense que
pratiquement toutes les jeunes femmes
travaillent donc est-ce que vous avez un
comparatif entre la santé mentale de
celle qui est avant de travailler pas et
celle qui maintenant parce que elles ont
des carrières hachées ou des
interruptions ont peut-être plus de
problèmes psychologiques comme vous ne
l'avez expliqué parce que c'était une
question que je voulais vous poser aussi
le pourquoi c'est intervenait si
tardivement mais vous y avez répondu
merci chers rapporteur donc je vous
laisse répondre et après je passerai la
parole au sénateurs qui sont présents et
qui souhaitent peut-être aussi vous
interpeller
je vais commencer à répondre par rapport
à l'évolution au fil des générations du
taux d'inactivité et de la norme
d'emploi donc en fait effectivement à
partir des années 60 les femmes sont
massivement rentrées dans l'emploi
et ça stagne à peu près depuis les
années 2000 on est un taux d'activité
qui est à peu près voilà autour de 85%
pour les 25-49 ans depuis les années
2000 si je me trompe pas à vérifier
évidemment et effectivement
cette féminisation du marché du travail
elle s'est pas fait toute seule elle
s'est faite parce qu'il y a une volonté
politique de développer l'emploi féminin
notamment via l'offre de garde je vais
aller politique familiales via la
quantité et la qualité des offres de
garde et en plus de ça cette
féminisation du marché du travail et les
concomitantes à la diffusion d'une norme
d'emploi c'est à dire qu'il est devenu
de plus en plus normal et attendu pour
une femme quelle occupe un emploi
lorsqu'elle émerve et donc effectivement
pour les femmes qui sont nées dans les
années
1930-1940 et qui rentrait sur le marché
du travail à un moment où le taux
d'emploi des femmes le taux d'activité
des femmes était de 30%
la norme était moins forte et ça peut
avoir directement un lien entre enfin
c'est c'est directement le lien avec les
conséquences de l'inactivité sur la
santé puisqu'on peut imaginer que le
stigmate dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
il est beaucoup il était beaucoup moins
fort pour ses femmes là c'est à dire
qu'il était beaucoup moins mal vu et
critiqué
socialement de ne pas occuper un emploi
et donc ce mécanisme qui fait que
l'inactivité peut être délétère ne
s'exerçait pas forcément pour ces femmes
là avec la féminisation du marché du
travail la norme d'emploi c'est diffusée
et donc ce stigmat est lié au fait
d'être en inactivité professionnelle et
devenue de plus en plus fort
donc les liens varient effectivement en
fonction des générations est-ce que
montre aujourd'hui les études et depuis
un certain moment c'est qu'en fait les
l'inactivité professionnelle reste
toujours présente donc je l'ai évoqué on
a toujours voilà 20% des maires de trois
enfants ou plus qui sont en inactivité
professionnelle entre 25 et 49 ans
d'après les données du recensement 2019
euh et en fait
ces femmes là la plupart du temps donc
il y a des études à partir de l'enquête
family employeur en fonction des
enquêtes à part des enquêtes mode de
garde à partir desquels des chercheuses
notamment je pense à Karine Brière ou
Dominique Méda ont montré que
effectivement quand on demandait aux
femmes pourquoi elles étaient en
inactivité professionnelle elle
répondait que voilà c'était pour leur
famille donc c'est un choix mais ensuite
qu'on leur demande de détailler plus
précisément ce qui les comptes le
contexte les configurations qui ont
entouré leur sortie du marché du travail
on se rend compte que souvent c'est lié
à des contraintes contraintes liées à
l'organisation du travail donc par
exemple à des horaires décalés qui sont
pas forcément compatibles avec le fait
de s'occuper de ses enfants contraintes
liées parfois à l'état du marché du
travail c'est à dire que les sorties du
marché du travail arrivent parfois en
même temps que un licenciement ou que la
fin d'un CDD donc en fait l'augmentation
de la précarité et des difficultés à
trouver un emploi vont
favoriser la sortie du marché du travail
autour des maternités puisque la
maternité va alors constituer un
échappatoire face à toutes ces
contraintes à s'insérer pérenne de façon
pérenne sur le marché du travail et avec
des conditions de travail plutôt bonnes
contrainte aussi liée au mode de garde
puisque des fois c'est difficile de
trouver une assistante maternelle ou une
crèche pour ses enfants donc oui
aujourd'hui c'est principalement des
contraintes qui entourent les sorties du
marché du travail et sur lesquels il
faut jouer contrainte qui ne sont pas
incompatibles avec le fait de dire
préférer rester en inactivité
professionnelle pour s'occuper de ses
enfants donc voilà la question du choix
pour les générations actuelles elle est
un petit peu compliquée pour les
générations
antérieures elles se posait même pas
vraiment puisqu'il était normal enfin
c'était une norme de ne pas être en
emploi
donc voilà en ce qui concerne mes les
apports que je peux donner vis-à-vis de
cette question là
je laisse la parole pour la suite ouais
alors bon je pense que là vous avez une
réponse une sociodémographe assez
nourrie moi ce que je peux vous dire par
rapport aux différences de génération
plus en termes de différence de
d'exposition
pas pas de parcours et de et de choix de
préférence ou de construction des
parcours de vie donc effectivement moi
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur les effets
différé donc des effets à long terme
donc c'est décidé qu'on regarde pas dans
les âges les plus jeunes donc on a pu
observer des différences entre les
femmes et les hommes rentrer sur le
marché du travail avant le début des
années 90 ou depuis des années 90 mais
quand on regarde le cancer on est obligé
d'avoir des populations déjà
d'un âge plus plus mûr
donc mais par contre ce qu'on voit par
exemple dans les statistiques accident
du travail maladie professionnelle c'est
que aussi bien chez les hommes que chez
les femmes il y a davantage d'accidents
de travail avec arrêt chez les plus
jeunes et c'est vrai aussi pour les
femmes pas que pour les hommes donc ça
concerne aussi les métiers et les
secteurs dans lesquels les femmes se
sincères et de manière générale un des
problèmes qui a
je pense en santé au travail c'est de
vouloir gérer la pénibilité par le biais
du recrutement et donc on revient à
l'effet du travail ça on va allouer on
va affecter les travailleurs les plus
jeunes et en meilleure santé au poste
les plus difficiles
pas forcément directement
mais en tout cas en terme de profilage
et donc effectivement il faut plutôt
réfléchir et ça c'est vraiment le credo
des ergonomes d'adapter le travail à
l'homme et à la femme plutôt que
d'essayer de faire l'inverse et donc il
y a un enjeu effectivement à ne pas
compromettre l'avenir des plus jeunes en
les affectant au motifs de protéger
aussi les plus âgés qui ont déjà
accumulé un certain nombre de pénibilité
à des tâches particulièrement difficiles
il faut continuer à améliorer les
conditions de travail pour tous et pour
toutes voilà
alors je crois que Annick jacmet voulait
compléter sa question oui oui j'ai
oublié presque la question la plus
importante à mes yeux
vous nous avez dit madame Beaufils qui
avait trois marqueurs par lesquels les
inégalités de santé fortment et pour
lesquelles les politiques publiques
peuvent intervenir alors qu'est-ce que
vous avez
identifié comme politique publique
existante incomplètes ou inexistante sur
lesquelles il faudrait travailler plus
spécialement et mettre en avant en fait
quelle solution vous préconisez après
toutes les études que vous avez faites
et les constats que vous en tirez
alors comme l'a dit Émilie tout à
l'heure voilà j'ai
identifié des politiques mais c'est très
général et ça a rien de révolutionnaire
les trois marqueurs donc que j'avais
identifié d'abord c'était que des
carrières avec des expositions
professionnelles avec de la précarité
avec de l'instabilité c'était lié à des
risques de santé plus tard dans la vie
pour les femmes donc là la solution ça
peut être par exemple de réduire
l'occurrence de ces carrières donc de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait moins de
précarité dans les carrières des femmes
de faire en sorte que les carrières des
femmes soient moins instables et de
réduire les expositions leurs fréquences
leurs cumulent ou alors les conséquences
de ces expositions sur la santé par des
adaptations des postes de travail par
exemple
ensuite en deuxième marqueur que j'avais
identifié c'était les traps à une
activité ça c'est un résultat très
important sur lequel je veux insister
c'est à dire qu'il y a beaucoup de
femmes qui interrompent leur emploi et
qui ne retournent pas sur le marché du
travail parce qu'elle considère qu'il
est impossible pour elle de retourner
dans le marché du travail soit parce
qu'elles ont essayé des fois et que en
fait c'était trop difficile qu'elles
n'ont pas été accompagnées soit parce
qu'elles occupaient un poste avec des
compétences techniques spécifiques que
le poste a évolué notamment via des
logiciels via l'informatique et donc
elle se sentent incapable de revenir
dans ces emplois là et je précise
qu'elle se sentent incapable ça serait
possible qu'elle revienne dans ses
impôts dans ses emplois là si on
développait des politiques qui
favoriseraient soit les reconversions
soit les retours en emploi des femmes
qui se sentent bloquées dans leur
inactivité professionnelle et donc qui
vont pas retourner sur le marché du
travail parce que voilà elle elle se
sentent incapable souvent il y a une
perte de confiance en soi aussi par
rapport au domaine professionnel qui
vient avec l'inactivité professionnelle
donc il faudrait jouer sur cet aspect là
du retour en emploi et réfléchir à des
politiques qui le favoriseraient ou en
tout cas qui feraient que les femmes qui
ont interrompu leur emploi même si elles
l'ont interrompre elle puisse revenir
après
soit parce que il y aurait des
dispositifs des tremplins qui le
permettraient soit parce qu'on réduirait
leur perte de confiance et ce sentiment
d'incapacité à réexercer un emploi et
ensuite le dernier marqueur c'était
voilà le fait que
dans certains cas l'inactivité
professionnelle je l'ai dit pour
certaines femmes c'est pas forcément un
problème si on a du patrimoine
et que donc ça nous met pas en péril du
point de vue économique effectivement on
peut ne pas exercer d'emploi ça nous
protège de pénibilité liée à l'emploi
c'est pas forcément une mauvaise chose
si notre conjoint a des revenus
importants voilà ça va pas non plus se
répercuter sur le niveau de vie mais en
revanche
quand on fait face à une séparation
conjugale ou lorsque notre conjoint a un
accident du travail dans ces cas-là
l'inactivité professionnelle elle va
devenir critique notamment par ses
conséquences économiques conséquences
économiques qui vont contraindre par
exemple voilà les femmes à rester en
emploi un âge très tardif parce que du
point de vue de leur pension de retraite
elles ne peuvent pas se permettre de
faire autrement et donc là les solutions
elles sont toutes des d'abord ça dit
qu'il faut encourager le maintien en
emploi pour puisque c'est événements et
séparations etc ça devient plus fréquent
donc pour que ces situations critiques
soient moins fréquentes il faut que les
femmes soient plus souvent en emploi et
arrivent à se maintenir en emploi
et ensuite on peut penser à des
dispositifs de filets de sécurité pour
que celle à qui ça arrive ne se retrouve
pas voilà dans des situations
extrêmement critiques du point de vue
économique
merci beaucoup pour ces éléments de
réponse je vais passer la parole à leur
d'Archos et puis Jean-Michel Arnaud et
puis je vous laisserai répondre à ces
dernières questions oui merci beaucoup
et merci pour ces
tableaux enfin c'est en tout cas cette
réunion qui est très très intéressante
moi je voulais savoir si vous aviez
également fait des études sur
le fait que les femmes
empêchaient par des problèmes de santé
ou de grossesse
reprenez plus rapidement leur activité
professionnelle par rapport aux hommes
je m'explique que ça soit dans un
traitement
de chimio ou de rayon
pour une grossesse de ne pas rester tout
son congé mat de maternité
soit en amont de l'accouchement soit
après et plus récemment mais je pense
que ça par contre c'est peut-être trop
tôt pour que vous ayez des études
concernant le covid je j'en ai eu
l'expérience autour de moi ou des femmes
revenaient finalement avec après un
covid quand même assez lourd plus
rapidement au travail que que les hommes
je ne dis pas chers confrères que les
hommes sont doués mais enfin on sait
très bien que lorsqu'ils ont un rhume
c'est ils sont à l'article de la mort
donc
j'exagère mais mais mais à peine mais
plus sérieusement voilà est-ce que vous
avez pu faire aussi des analyses de cet
ordre sur la reprise d'activité
lors de problèmes de santé ou problèmes
de santé c'est un vrai problème de santé
mais au moins des grossesses
merci je vais passer la parole
Jean-Michel Arnaud nous sommes filmés
donc si tu te retrouves à la Une de
quotidien un soir
bien je ne sais pas si c'est l'homme
Douillet qui va s'exprimer mais mais
dans tous les cas je voulais vous masser
d'abord de vous exposer et de votre
parfaite maîtrise de ces sujets j'avais
deux questions d'abord on est ce qui a
été dit rapidement tout à l'heure en
plein débat sur sur les retraites je
voulais savoir si vous aviez des
éléments dans vos analyses dans vos
travaux qui permettent d'avoir
un regard peut-être maîtrisé pour nous
parlementaire qui auront à statuer sur
ce sujet sur la reprise d'activité à
l'issue de la période familiale intense
des femmes ça y est grosso modo de 50
ans puisque on a un enjeu sur les 50-65
ans dans le cas de la réforme des
retraites en cours et si vous aviez sur
sur ce sujet des éléments importants de
connaissances permettant
d'expliquer ou de trouver des arguments
qui pourraient distinguer dans nos
débats la situation des femmes des
hommes face à l'âge pivot de retraite
qui me semble être un sujet quand même
important au vu des différences que vous
avez souligné de parcours de vie la
deuxième question j'entamerai là ce que
je veux être le plus concis possible
vous avez essentiellement fait état de
travaux sur la Seine-Saint-Denis pour ce
qui vous concerne madame
et évidemment ce sujet est un sujet
important puisque la Seine-Saint-Denis
conjugue cumule un certain nombre de
spécificités est-ce que vous avez dans
vos travaux des références aussi sur
l'extrême ruralité ou de la ruralité
forte puisqu'on a eu des travaux
importants lors du début de session où
il y a un an maintenant un an et demi et
s'il y a une spécificité aussi rurale
sur les sujets que vous nous avez
présenté aujourd'hui
je merci Jean-Michel pour revenir sur ce
rapport effectivement femme et ruralité
et je crois que la question de
Jean-Michel aussi est très intéressante
dans la mesure où on peut avoir aussi
les freins qui empêchent des femmes de
revenir au travail dans les périodes
charnières que vous avez évoqué et donc
est-ce qu'il y a des politiques
publiques terme de mobilité notamment à
ce que vous avez identifié ces sujets
merci à vous deux pour ces questions je
vous laisse répondre et mesdames
alors moi donc encore une fois vu mon
domaine de compétence pour j'aurai moins
d'éléments peut-être que ma collègue à
vous donner sur cette question à la fois
de la reprise plus rapide du travail
après un arrêt maladie ou un congé
maternité ou un congé parental ou qui
est une forme de présentéisme on
pourrait dire des femmes plus
importantes que les hommes ou sur la
question des retraites ou je pense c'est
qu'il y avait eu des travaux
des commissions Haddock sur les parcours
des femmes et des hommes mais j'ai pas
les éléments à vous communiquer
directement je sais qu'on a des
collègues à Lynette qui ont été très
sollicitées
avant la crise covid notamment
au moment de la crise covid sur ces
questions donc je pourrais les renvoyer
vers vous si vous le souhaitez
pour donc pour répondre plus directement
sur la Seine-Saint-Denis donc d'une part
un commentaire c'est que donc
effectivement ce sont des travaux qui
ont été localisés en Seine-Saint-Denis
mais qui nous apportent des
enseignements très enfin de porter plus
large on va dire sur les expositions
cancérogènes
au travail pour la question de la
ruralité c'est une très bonne question
mais alors effectivement je n'ai pas de
réponse à vous apporter
à ma connaissance dans la
statistique publique donc j'ai pas
connaissance d'enquête à dock comme on
dit vrai qu'il aurait été
assemblée spécifiquement pour regarder
la question des conditions de travail et
de la santé dans ces contextes mais il
me semble que dans la statistique
publique on a au moins la taille de
l'unité
urbaine de résidence etc alors je sais
je sais pas comment on peut recouper les
informations
j'ai pas connaissance de travaux qui
étaient faits sur ce sujet mais de toute
évidence ne serait-ce pour la question
des accidents de trajet éventuelles et
des possibles et bien sûr de la
structuration de l'emploi
c'est ça semble particulièrement
pertinent
alors en ce qui concerne les femmes
empêchées par des problèmes de santé
est-ce qu'elle reprennent plus vite que
les hommes alors j'ai pas d'éléments
là-dessus et je préfère pas dire quelque
chose parce que ça reposerait sur des
suppositions mais je pourrais regarder
si j'ai connaissance de travaux qui ont
très assez question et je vous les
communiquerai de même pour la reprise
les comportements d'activité des femmes
et des hommes autour de l'âge pivot moi
c'est vrai que je me suis surtout j'ai
surtout étudié la période 18-50 ans donc
avant ces âges-là justement parce que en
termes de données ça devenait assez
compliqué à traiter en termes de statut
d'emploi etc donc j'aurais pas beaucoup
d'éléments à vous apporter là dessus en
revanche en termes de ce qui facilite
les reprises après des interruptions
d'emploi ce que j'ai pu identifier c'est
le type de contrat avant l'interruption
qui donne en fait une idée de la
sécurité de l'emploi et de l'inscription
dans l'emploi dont
bénéficié les femmes en question donc le
de secteur et donc effectivement par
exemple les fonctionnaires elles peuvent
toujours reprendre leur emploi et ça va
faciliter leur retour en emploi des fois
après 10 ans d'interruption donc ça ça
leur permet de sortir de ces trappes à
une activité et dans le secteur privé ou
secteur public en CDD c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué puisque effectivement il
y a pas de dispositif pour retourner
enfin l'emploi n'est pas garanti au
retour ensuite ce qui est ce qui est
assez important c'est tout simplement la
durée de l'interruption plus elle est
longue moins les chances de reprise sont
importantes puisque plus ces obstacles
que j'ai évoqués et notamment ces
difficultés perçues anticipées
rencontrées au retour en emploi vont
être importantes et il y a aussi la
question de la santé qui recoupe tout ça
puisque
souvent les femmes qui essayent de
reprendre un emploi après voilà 15-20
ans d'interruption n'ont pas la même
forme physique que lorsqu'elles sont
sorties de cet emploi et donc elle elle
ressentent comme très difficile ce
retour en emploi même si l'emploi et le
même donc la santé va aussi voilà
troubles de santé ce sont développées
pendant la période d'interruption ça va
être également plus compliqué de revenir
par la suite puisque comme la bien
souligné Émilie l'emploi est un facteur
enfin la santé est un facteur d'emploi
c'est à dire qu'on a besoin d'être en
bonne santé pour reprendre un emploi et
notamment en bonne santé mentale puisque
la santé mentale va directement
influencer sur les possibilités qu'on
perçoit à revenir en emploi donc si on
est dans un état dépressif on va se
sentir d'autant plus incapable et
en incapacité pour reprendre un emploi
voilà
une dernière question
vous parliez à l'instant de l'état
dépressif est-ce que dans vos études
vous avez pu faire le distinguo entre
parce qu'on voit quand même qu'il y a de
plus en plus de couples qui séparent
donc des coupes qui séparent ça veut
dire des femmes et des hommes qui sont
mal dans leur couple est-ce que vous
avez pu faire le distinguo entre
l'origine de ces troubles finalement
est-ce que c'est le travail ou est-ce
que c'est
être mal dans son couple qui influe
après aussi sur la qualité et le
ressenti au travail voilà parce qu'on
parle beaucoup des des vous nous avez
dit que les carrières hachées que les
carrières sont les en fin finalement de
carrière on se rend compte qu'à ces
problèmes un peu psychologiques mais
est-ce que vous avez pu faire justement
le la distinction entre l'origine qui
vient bien du travail et l'origine aussi
d'être mal dans son couple
si si on arrive à faire un distinguo
entre les deux
une distinction entre
on parle on parle beaucoup de on parle
beaucoup finalement de l'influence du
travail sur les problèmes psychologiques
ou sur les dépressions ou sur mais quand
on voit la stabilité dans les couples ou
le nombre de couples qui séparent ça
veut dire aussi qu'un couple qui sépare
ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas bien dans
son couple donc il y a forcément aussi
des répercussions la dépression la
difficulté alors est-ce que dans vos
études vous pouvez faire le distinguo
entre l'origine finalement de ses
dépressions puisqu'on parle
principalement des dépressions au
travail mais à côté du travail il y a
quand même une vie personnelle qui
influe aussi sur la santé mentale et
psychique alors est-ce que vous pouvez
faire un distinguo justement où est-ce
que c'est pas pris en compte dans les
études alors nous dans les études on
contrôle toujours par la situation
conjugale par l'étude conjugale c'est à
dire on regarde les liens entre ces
interruptions et la santé à situation
conjugale égale donc voilà c'est bien
pris en compte ensuite moi je l'ai pas
fait directement mais il y a toute une
littérature qui documente les
conséquences des ruptes sur conjugales
sur la santé et notamment une un élément
qui est assez intéressant une étude de
de Emmanuel cambois qui montrait que
pour les hommes les conséquences de la
séparation sur la santé mentale passe
par une perte de soutien social c'est à
dire que les hommes ont des risques de
développer des troubles dépressifs après
une dépression parce que ils perdent un
réseau social des contacts des relations
des occasions sociabilité tandis que
pour les femmes les conséquences en
termes de santé mentale de ces
séparations passe par la perte de
ressources économique donc ça c'est
assez intéressant de voir que les voix
qui conduisent à la mauvaise santé à
l'issue d'une séparation sont distinctes
pour les hommes et les femmes et passe
par des ressources sociales pour les
femmes non ressources économiques pour
les femmes
qu'elle passe par des ressources
sociales pour les hommes
merci beaucoup
voilà juste pour revenir un petit peu en
arrière sur les politiques publiques
donc je sais que ça portait
spécifiquement sur les carrières des
femmes et des hommes si revient plus
spécifiquement sur les questions de
santé au travail parce que là on est
plus sur des questions d'égalité
professionnelle qui impactent bien
entendu la santé au travail mais et la
santé au-delà du travail enfin la santé
et le travail et le travail la santé
dans les deux sens
donc je pense qu'il y a des des choses
importantes à avoir en tête c'est que
bien sûr il y a les politiques de
prévention qui sont essentielles et donc
j'en ai les approches nécessaires tenir
compte au fait aussi des différents
sommes femmes dans les dispositifs de
traçabilité les facteurs de pénibilité
qui sont retenus après pour établir la
pénibilité des carrières les âges de
retraite etc tout ça c'est très
important
mais il y a également la question de la
réparation pour rappeler que la
réparation des des attentes à la santé
et au travail a été pensé non seulement
pour dédommager indemniser les victimes
mais aussi comme un incitatif pour les
employeurs à adopter des mesures de
protection de la santé des travailleurs
qui obligation légale obligation de
sécurité de résultat et donc à ce titre
on peut souligner que le système de
réparation bien qu'il soit
relativement plus ouvert en France que
dans d'autres pays d'Europe comme le
monde des études comparatives reste
encore très limité en termes
d'accessibilité et notamment les
problèmes de santé psychique ne sont pas
pris en compte
or on l'a vu ils peuvent toucher
particulièrement les femmes mais bon je
veux pas non plus éluder les problèmes
de santé qui concernent les hommes et
qui et qui rendent enfin pour lesquelles
l'accès à la réparation ma vie
professionnelle et est également
difficile donc il faut vraiment intégrer
ces dimensions de genre
mais les dimensions plus plus larges
d'invisibilité de non recours au droit
de non accès aux droits dans le
dispositif de réparation et puis j'ai
envie de dire et là je prêche pour pour
notre chapelle de chercheurs et de
producteurs de statistiques aussi c'est
que on a vraiment besoin que au-delà de
nos grandes enquêtes dans lesquelles on
est bien conscient de ces choses et on
intègre le maximum de de données
socio-démograph contextuelle pour
comprendre la construction des parcours
de vie et de santé on a besoin aussi que
la statistique publique inclut
systématiquement alors bien sûr le sexe
c'est déjà le cas la profession c'est
pas le cas sur les certificats de décès
on n'a pas de données fiable sur la
profession on a une donnée approchante
sur la position sociale qui va commencer
en début d'année à être recueilli y
compris chez les inactifs et les
retraités au moment du décès alors
qu'avant ça concernait uniquement les
actifs au moment du décès mais qui
n'étaient pas exploitables et on aurait
besoin également d'avoir des éléments
sur l'histoire migratoire des personnes
puisque
il est important de tenir compte des
mécanismes plus larges de division
sociale du travail et des risques qui
sont bien des mécanismes de division
sexuelle mais qui sont aussi des des
mécanismes de division en fonction de
l'origine ça a été documenté dans
d'autres pays et la France n'échappe pas
à cette exception on est simplement
moins bien outillés pour pour le montrer
jusqu'ici
et bien écoutez merci mesdames pour ces
réponses complètes je pense que votre
intervention de la fin est là est assez
éloquente pour nos rapporteurs parce que
la santé des femmes au travail elle est
liée au travail mais le travail évolue
très vite et c'est vrai que lorsque vous
nous avez proposé tout à l'heure en 2010
des résultats on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui ben oui la covid ça a
modifié aussi l'organisation du travail
le rapport au travail et et des
nouvelles méthodes de travail sont
apparues le télétravail on a on a
désormais un télétravail qui impacte
aussi de manière importante et peut-être
différenciée les femmes et les hommes
donc la nécessité d'avoir des données
genrées des données également par
secteur d'activité et des données aussi
par taille d'entreprise et Marie-Pierre
Richer le disait tout à l'heure donc on
le voit c'est un sujet extrêmement vaste
parce que le sujet n'a pas été longtemps
de documenté et que on doit faire ce
travail d'état des lieux aujourd'hui et
de prospective aussi pour demain parce
que les inégalités salariales les
inégalités d'emploi ont un impact ça on
l'avait imaginé sur la santé des femmes
tout au long de leur vie mais vous
l'avez dit et moi je l'ai un peu
découvert ce matin l'inactivité aussi à
un impact considérable sur la santé des
femmes lorsqu'elles sont contraintes du
fait des parcours et des époques
charnières de maternité notamment et
bien à quitter un travail et ça pour moi
c'est une nouveauté je n'avais pas vu
cette
inactivité pardon comme une mise en
danger de la santé des femmes à ce
moment-là donc merci mesdames pour ces
éléments de précision ce matin n'hésitez
pas comme je vous l'ai dit à nous
envoyer des données chiffrées j'en Rey
sectorisé parce que on l'imagine bien la
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est une photographie
mais c'est pas forcément la photographie
de tous nos territoires donc
nous sommes avis de recevoir encore
d'autres informations qui pourront à
aider nos rapporteurs à avancer sur ce
travail de la santé des femmes au
travail merci